why do you think the spot etf like what
what's the issues there uh and obviously
given the fact that you guys have put
forward applications and you know gone
back and forth regulators i don't know
what you can say what you can't say but
just kind of there's a futures etf in
the united states there's spot etfs and
futures etfs uh for bitcoin
internationally what's your read on uh
kind of regulatory environment and what
it'll take to get a spot etf for bitcoin
in the united states
i mean look i could talk about this for
for a super long time um i i think what
i've said is the sec is holding a
bitcoin etf hostage
uh until they get jurisdiction on over
the underlying uh crypto markets which
they don't have right now
and so that's that's that narrow issue i
mean the broader issue and i wrote a
piece on stable coins a couple of weeks
ago
is that i think the whole regulatory
dialogue is is not very healthy right
now because i think there's dialogue on
shows like yours where there's actually
back and forth a pro and con but when
you get to dc it's
one congressman doing their view another
senator doing their view you listen to
the hearings
you know and the banking regulators want
stable coins to be banking products and
the
future you know the cftc wants them to
be maybe derivatives or their cash
commodities i mean it's everyone's
talking their own book and there's not a
lot of thinking through of really what
these things are
if you could just wave a magic wand and
you know you were sec chairman for a day
or president for a day or what pick your
kind of role uh what do you think would
be the ideal scenario for uh the
industry is it just approve a bitcoin
spot etf and let the market kind of take
it from there are there other things
that you think would be uh worth
having conversation around
i think we need um i actually i don't
know if i really care about that so much
anymore because so many people can buy
bitcoin uh you know kind of retail i
mean it would be nice but i think you
know in europe um pop we have eight
different exchange-traded products so
seven single tokens and a multi-token so
just bitcoin okay but it really would be
nice for retail investors through their
brokerage accounts to have access to
many more things in the ecosystem that's
just not happening right
so um i'm a little i'm really of two
minds i think it would be nice to try
some safe harbors like i said trade
stable coins like etfs and see how that
goes if you're really concerned about a
regulator a custodian and an auditor
looking at the assets behind i'll call
them the traditional style stable coins
because there's so many types
let's just start there but of course but
at this rate nothing's happening so i'm
almost the other mind that says just
forget it let all the disruption happen
because dc is never going to get
organized if they do anything they're
more likely to mess it up and create
big regulatory barriers which is really
bad hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time